cdu und grüne planen gerade in nordrhein
westfalen einen neuen koalitionsvertrag
man hat sich schon auf eckpunkte
geeinigt einer dieser punkte ist dass
die herabsenkung des wahlalters auf 16
jahre und die begründung die man liefert
ist einerseits die schlechte
wahlbeteiligung bei der letzten
landtagswahl und dass man eben die
demokratie stärken will zitat auch
beteiligungsmöglichkeiten vor allem für
diejenigen ausbauen die bislang zu wenig
repräsentiert sind ich würde ganz klar
sagen den kindern ein wahlrecht gibt ja
stärkt die demokratie nicht sondern er
manipuliert eigentlich genau genommen
die demokratie weil kinder sehr anfällig
sind und sich vor allen dingen gerade
auch in dem alter wie sehen es eher von
influenza und von youtube politisieren
lassen aber nicht irgendwie von
schulbildung die sie inzwischen auch
boykottieren um das klima zu retten wir
haben auch ein paradoxon hier weil wir
einerseits jugendliche bis zum alter von
21 jahren teilweise noch unter
welpenschutz stellen im strafrecht weil
wir davon ausgehen dass dass wir sie mit
jugendstrafrecht noch bestrafen wir
haben 18 jährige dürfen für sich kein
tattoo stechen lassen und dürfen nicht
mehr in die öffentliche sauna ohne
erlaubnis ihrer eltern jetzt sollen sie
aber wählen dürfen ich hätte einen
gegenvorschlag zu bringen anstatt das
wahlalter auf 16 jahre runter zu legen
um kindern und jugendlichen besser zu
repräsentieren sollten wir endlich ein
familienwahlrecht einführen und diese
stimme den eltern geben eltern kümmern
sich um ihre kinder vertreten ihre
kinder überall juristisch und das wäre
tatsächlich auch ein quantensprung in
der demokratie wenn tatsächlich familien
für jedes familienmitglied eine stimme
hätte und und dann würden wir vielleicht
auch die familienpolitik bekommen die
ihren namen auch verdient er frei wäre
das nicht ein super vorschlag für die
union weil die union kommt ja bei den
jungen leuten nicht so gut an die fdp
und grüne also eigentlich müsste doch
sagen danke direkt mit wer also da gab
es auch schon andere zeiten und die
werden auch wieder kommen davon bin ich
überzeugt wir werden bei den jungen
wieder in sein ja davon bin ich
überzeugt das werden wir durch gute
politik
erreichen
ich finde ich finde den befund etwas
problematisch das muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen und würde es deswegen auch nicht
so apodiktisch formulieren auch wenn ich
jetzt auch nicht ein großer anhänger des
wahlrechts mit 16 bin ich finde einfach
man muss aufpassen dass rechte und
pflichten nicht auseinanderfallen und
sie haben ein paar beispiele genannt es
ist in der tat nicht unproblematisch
wenn man einerseits nicht in jedem kino
film gehen darf aber auf der anderen
seite
parlamente mit welt das passt irgendwie
nicht so recht zusammen der handyvertrag
die man nicht selber abschließen darf
ohne zustimmung der eltern
aber auf der anderen seite welt mann und
deswegen finde ich schon immer dass es
notwendig ist rechte und pflichten
zusammenzubringen das ist übrigens
nichts statisches wir hatten früher auch
mal die volljährigkeit mit 21 und die
hat man zu recht auf 18 heruntergesetzt
aber etwas was sich im übrigen auch im
grunde nicht akzeptieren kann ist dass
wir planmäßig so muss man ja sagen wenn
man es sich faktisch anschaut bis zum 21
lebensjahr jugendstrafrecht anwenden das
finde ich aber viele und problem das wir
für leute die genau wissen was sie tun
und das ist bei 19 20 21 jährigen der
fall da immer noch eine falsche milde an
den tag legen also mir geht es eher um
die grundsätzliche frage rechte und
pflichten zusammenzubringen man kann
nicht von meinen nur das gute haben und
das andere beiseite legen wir meinen die
runde herr werner sind die 21 jährigen
also die 18-jährigen frau kelle möchte
ist auf 21 haben sind ich weiß nicht auf
21 haben ich will es nicht auf 16 senken
ich finde dass das wahlalter mit 18 ein
gutes alter ist man wird volljährig man
hat eben die verpflichtungen dann auch
und dann kriegt man auch das wahlrecht
aber dass man ein recht verliehen
bekommt ohne dass man jemals
konsequenzen für das tragen muss was man
da tut oder auch dass man das geistig
nicht in der lage also vielleicht zu
artikeln völlig in ordnung 16 haben
genau ich finde das 18 die folie also
diese juristische volljährigkeit ein
gutes alter ist es auch das altern die
man sich selber auch wählen lassen kann
also wir haben im moment haben wir ja
sozusagen eine einheit in dem alter wo
man wählen darf sich auch selbst zur
wahl stellen dafür üblicherweise
üblicherweise und und das würde ich in
bundeshand abgeordneten haben nein ich
finde auch nicht dass sie will ich habe
ich kenne genug teenager und deswegen
denke ich an die wir sollten
janacek die grünen würden ja davon
profitieren wenn das wahlrecht ab 16
wäre es genau das ist jetzt nicht der
punkt für mich allein
nordrhein-westfalen wir das glaubst du
jetzt vereinbart in der sondierung mitte
ja jetzt hier diego in österreich gibt
es das schon mal ich habe zwei kinder
sind jetzt 12 14 16 aber gerade mich
wenn ich wählen lassen die youtuber
generation ist ja durchaus auch
politisiert in teilen die schauen sich
auch nicht nur dinge an die jetzt
irgendwelche insta blogger machen
sondern heute auch die influenza die
machen für eine schmink tutorials das
aber es gibt doch beinahe hätten wir den
re so zum beispiel der sehr kontrovers
ist bei uns auch mal in der fraktion zur
diskussion ich habe mich durchaus auch
nicht nur in die wieder gefunden also da
ist spannung da aber sind auf jeden fall
ist ein gruppe seiner videos das kann
ich ihnen nicht schon das ist nämlich
gar darüber nach was ist nun ganz
erschreckend dass die influenza die
polit in friends ja gar nicht so sehr
die ganz junge erreichen das denken
spricht haben dafür das gar nicht ja
sauer sind dann wenn sie 20 und 25 dann
kann die 16 ja auch will wir möchten ja
auch ab 18 das ist bleibt fraglich halte
ist überhaupt nicht für für
verbesserungswürdig oder für ich halte
es nicht für nötig dass wir hier
irgendetwas verändern weil es mir
einfach sorgen macht das hier eigentlich
nur eigentlich es ist fast eine
populistische forderung man weiß eben
gerade auch von grüner seite
tschuldigung irgendwie das dass die
jugendlichen in dem alter dazu neigen
eher die grünen links alternativ zu
wählen das heißt vor allen dingen die
grünen würden massiv davon profitieren
im moment irgendwas ein problem dass das
mal sagen darf wir haben ja ein alter
spaltung in der gesellschaft und die
wird ja nicht geringer also wir werden
eine ältere gesellschaft das ist so und
das heißt immer mehr menschen über 60
dominieren die entscheidungen dann jetzt
komme ich da mal rein in 15 jahren wird
sie nur noch aber es ist natürlich für
eine demokratie auch nicht toll wenn
entscheidungen also wenn man die leute
unter 18 komplett ausgeklammert und
deswegen irgendwann wird auch den eltern
aber warum die kinder
ich bin doch für alles was meine kinder
tun verantwortlich ich vertrete sie
juristisch in allen belangen dass es
gesetzlich so geregelt warum sollte ich
denn nicht im interesse meiner kinder
handeln und im übrigen wenn sie das
familienwahlrecht heben dann geben sie
nicht nur den 16 und 17 jährigen ein
eine stimme sondern sie würden jedem
kind eine stimme geben jaunde jünger die
kinder sind umso mehr sind sie betroffen
von der politik die sie und sie gerade
machen ja das heißt das heißt wenn sie
wirklich nachhaltig jedem kind eine
stimme in der politik geben wollen dann
sollten sie den eltern für jedes kind
eine stimme geben und dann hätten wir
auch in corona politik zum beispiel die
belange der kinder ganz anderes vor